bill and ted will finally face the music
but for long time pals keanu reeves and
alex winter
this big screen reunion was long overdue
i'm tired dude ted we have a destiny to
fulfill
did you guys easily slip right back into
bill and ted mode it's an extraordinary
situation in the sense to revisit a
character
30 years later i mean we did a lot of
prep we
we did a lot of talking about the
characters and there was a moment where
we just had to
just kind of do it you know not talking
exactly nearly 30 years after their
bogus journey
bill and ted still have a lot in common
with her younger selves
[Music]
they're still in the band wild stallions
they'll time travel and phone booths
they'll meet alternate reality bill and
ted's
no way but now they have wives and
daughters although it looks like their
vocabulary hasn't changed much
oh at what point did you guys realize
that these characters had become
pop culture phenomenons i mean early
days you know
people kind of sharing lines or you know
saying like be excellent or
party on party on dudes e.t has been
with keanu and alex since the beginning
of their
excellent adventure back in 1991 here's
what they thought about a third film
built head three who knows what do you
think of those two dudes right there
they're full of life we had a lot of fun
we love working with each other but we
did not
think about making a third one we had
some edge to us
i think that's kind of yeah we did a
little a little bit of edge
yeah fourth one guys are you gonna be
back for more
hello the fans it's up to the fans
matrix four you're shooting it right now
how's it going cause you are looking a
little neo over there
i know kung fu yeah it's going great i'm
really grateful to be here
to be playing a role and having a chance
to make a
really awesome film
you